John Bolton's book excerpt up ends the
Trump defense team Pam Bondi
deconstructs Hunter Biden and it's
DEFCON one for Joe Biden against Bernie
Sanders i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show the ben shapiro show is
sponsored by expressive VPN stand up for
your digital rights today visit
expressvpn dot-com slash Ben so let's
begin with everything impeachment
related because let's face it right now
impeachment and 2020 are all tied
together in a ball it is very obvious at
this point that the president is not
going to be impeached that does not mean
that he cannot be damaged by the
impeachment hearings and this is
particularly true when you keep putting
forward foolish defenses so the fact of
the matter is very simple here the Trump
defense team was putting forward a
defense that Trump wanted them to put
forward he was not putting forward his
own best defense this appointed Andy
McCarthy has made a national review it's
point that I've been making for
literally months at this point which is
that President Trump's the best defense
from the beginning as soon as it became
clear that there was in fact a quid pro
quo was obvious yes a quid pro quo
happened
no the quid pro quo is not impeachable
and even if you don't like the quid pro
quo even if you think the quid pro quo
is bad that does not make it impeachable
president Trump rightly suspected that
Ukraine had interfered in the 2016
election not to the same extent as the
Russians and not in replacement of the
Russians but he was right to suspect
that the Ukrainians were interfering
into the 2016 election because there are
multiple credible media reports on that
subject and he was being fed bad
information by Rudy Giuliani about
everything that was going on in Ukraine
ranging from the CrowdStrike
Hillary Clinton's server being buried in
the woods outside of Kyiv or some such
nonsense to the hunter Biden stuff which
indeed was suspicious and because of
that he wanted all of that investigated
and so he used military aides Ukraine as
a way to leverage investigations out of
Ukraine that's not impeachable you may
not like his judgment you may think it's
bad you may think that it's
rough-and-tumble you may think that he
shouldn't be using foreign policy in
order to push for investigations that he
could have done through the FBI or the
DOJ all of that is subject for elections
it is not subject for impeachment right
that should have been his argument all
along but because President Trump is
pathologically incapable of
acknowledging that he has ever made a
mistake and because President Trump rips
anybody who ever criticizes him as the
worst person in the world
president
defense team was then put in the
position of making an argument that is
not factually based namely that Trump
held up military aid for things having
to do nothing with investigations now
the problem with that is that sooner or
later there was going to be somebody in
Trump's inner circle who said something
different and in fact we've already seen
people and from senator circle saying
things that are different for example
McMullen II his Office of Management and
Budget chief the guy who is now his
chief of staff he suggested in a press
conference openly that yes there was a
quid pro quo no the quid pro quo is not
legitimate that is a fair defense and
now john bolton is suggesting the same
thing and team Trump is being sort of
upended by the supposed revelation now
again that shouldn't have been a
revelation the normal response from Team
Trump should have been right that's
correct he did withhold the aid
contingent on Ukraine doing
investigations but there is nothing
illegal about that nor is there anything
impeachable about that but because
president Trump insists that his people
always defend and they can never make a
strategic retreat because he insist that
his people always line up their defenses
at the first point of contact and then
hold the line no matter what this leads
to untenable situations where they are
flanked and this is sort of what has
happened here with team Trump and
doesn't mean he's gonna be impeached it
does mean that it is I would say very
likely at this point that the Senate
Republicans are going to allow the
witness are going to allow John Bolton's
testify Wars before if john bolton had
come out and said this notice said we
don't need the testimony we already know
all of this all of this was covered by
fiona hill now because trump has come
out and calls his own national security
adviser a liar we got a problem on our
hands and you can see the New York Times
editorial board is over the moon about
this they're extremely happy about all
of this the New York Times editorial
board today says it's just possible the
common-sense in reality have a shot at
prying open the doors to the Senate
chamber after all after Republican
senators claimed it was perfectly
reasonable to put a United States
Presidents on trial without hearing from
any witnesses a few of them are showing
signs of recognizing that the truth
matters or at least that the American
people believe it does what has changed
shocking but not surprising revelations
from John Bolton's book manuscripts
which the New York Times reported over
the weekend have made impossible to
ignore what everyone has known for
months president Trump withheld hundreds
of millions of dollars in military aides
Ukraine to benefit himself politically
and against the strenuous objections of
his top aides and both parties in
Congress okay now again that is actually
not what Bolton charges well Bolton
charges that Trump was
interested in 2016 which is exactly what
some of us have been saying for months
and months and months and months and if
Trump had just admitted and said listen
again you may not like my judgment but
beans I've got an election 11 months
just deal with it that way if you'd said
that this whole thing would have been
over a long time ago he didn't say that
and so now everything Bolton is saying
is being treated as a massive revelation
with actual ramifications we'll get to
more of this in just one second we will
also get to Kim Trump making a
counter-argument it's gonna hurt Joe
Biden moving forward into the 2020
primaries first let us talk about how
foolish it is not to protect yourself
digitally and the fact is that you
wouldn't leave your car unlocked on the
street and what are the chances this
one's gonna break into your car on the
street the chances are fairly low or
unless you live in a high crime area
probably you could leave your car
unlocked on the street and everything
would be fine but you're not gonna leave
your car unlocked because why would you
do that like there's there's just no
point you can leave your front door
unlocked even though the chances of you
being broken into are pretty low well
then why would you leave all of your
online data available for anyone to grab
especially when you can do something
super easy like using expressvpn
expressvpn is the software I and
thousands of my fans use every day to
protect our data online in the time
since I started using expressvpn hacking
methods I have actually grown more
sophisticated they continue to grow more
sophisticated
that is why expressvpn is constantly
updating their own technology to ensure
that you are protected and we at daily
wire invest thousands of dollars a month
on online security I personally only
have to spend a few bucks a month that's
because I'm using expressvpn I've been
talking about expressvpn on my show for
a long time now you wouldn't leave your
car unless you went leave it front door
unlock go make sure that your internet
data is protected coach account Express
at VPN it is fast it is quick it is easy
with one click of a button you are now
protected go check them out at
expressvpn comm slash ben and when you
use that slash pen you get an extra
three months of expressvpn for free
protect your internet today with the VPN
I trust to keep my data safe go to
expressvpn comm slash Ben to get started
again
that's expressive VPN comm slash Ben to
get started so as I say the New York
Times is treating Bolton's words as a
revelation and of course you're seeing
Republican senators who are now being
ripped up and down by team Trump saying
that perhaps we are going to have to
have witnesses so Susan Collins the
senator from Maine she came out
yesterday she said yeah probably at some
point we're probably gonna have to have
witnesses she put out a statement she
said from the beginning I said that in
fairness to both parties the decision on
whether or not to call
should be made after both the house
managers and the presidents attorneys
have had the opportunity to present
their cases I've always said I was
likely to votes call witnesses just as I
did in the 1999 Clinton trial the
reports about John Bolton's book
strengthen the case for witnesses and
have prompted a number of conversations
among my colleagues okay well this is
fully expected they should not have been
any great shocked Collins by the way was
on the fence she was willing to not call
witnesses if they didn't have anything
new to tell but that relied very much on
the story the Trump was telling MIT
Romney says the same thing he says
probably we're gonna end up having
witnesses here now people are treating
Romney as though he's doing this because
he hates Trump or something that this is
all be personal animus hey the reality
is I think they're probably more than
two votes to have witnesses in the
Senate I don't think that John Bolton's
testimony is going to lead to
impeachment I'd be really surprised if
it did but I think that there are a lot
of Republicans who are in purple states
and thinking do I want to lose my seat
over the image of me covering for the
president when he is going up directly
against his own national security
advisor probably not here is Senator
Romney that says for some time that I
hope to be able to hear John Bolton I
think with a story that came out
yesterday it's increasingly apparent it
would be important to hear from John
Bolton I of course will make a final
decision on witnesses after we've heard
from
the prosecution can also the defense but
I think at this stage it's pretty fair
to say both John Bolton has a relevant
testimony to provide to those of us who
are sitting in impartial justice
I think it's increasingly likely that
other Republicans will will join those
of us who think we should hear from John
Bolton hey that is again not
particularly surprising and it's also
not surprising given the fact that the
people who are closest to Trump are now
having to put out statements that at the
very least columns of question in their
old statement so I point out Mick
Mulvaney statements on John Bolton he
gave a statement yesterday talking about
Bolton's claims that Mulvaney had been
part of conversations in which the the
aid was discussed so Mulvaney did put
out a statement yesterday Maggie
Haberman of the New York Times actually
tweeted it out it said the latest story
from the New York Times coordinated with
a book launch has more to do with
publicity than the truth John Bolton
never informed Mulvaney of any concerns
surrounding Bolton's purported August
conversation with the president nor did
mr. Mulvaney ever have a conversation
with the President or anyone else
indicating that Ukrainian military aid
was withheld in exchange for a Ukrainian
investigation of buries m'a the Biden's
or the 2016 election further up mr.
Mulvaney has no recollection of any
conversation with mr. Giuliani
resembling that reportedly described in
mr. Bolton's manuscript as it was mr.
MoMA Viennese practice to excuse himself
from conversations between the president
and his personal counsel to preserve any
attorney-client privilege
now we haven't actually seen Bolton's
manuscript remember so we don't actually
know what Bolton is claiming but there's
one sentence of that statement that
seems to contradict Mick Mulvaney right
Mick Mulvaney said that he had never had
a conversation with Trump or anyone else
indicating that military aid was
withheld in exchange for a Ukrainian
investigation of Bereza the Biden's or
the 2016 election and then what exactly
was Mick Mulvaney talking about when he
specifically held a press conference
suggesting that sure a quid pro quos
happened in foreign policy all the time
the question is whether that is legit or
not and you can see the differences even
within trumps defense team in the
defenses they are presenting so on the
one hand you have members of Team Trump
saying there was no quid pro quo at all
which of course is the case the Trump
would prefer be put out there but it's
not the smart case and then you have the
case put out there by lawyers who
actually know what the law is and know
what they are doing like Alan Dershowitz
so Alan Dershowitz for all of the talk
about how he's been consigned to hell
SNL actually can sign him to hell over
the weekend for the grave crime of
defending Trump in this impeachment
trial so weird they didn't care when he
was friends
for Epstein they didn't care when he was
or at least defense lawyer for Jeffrey
Epstein they didn't care when Alan
Dershowitz was defending OJ Simpson
didn't care about any of that the moment
that he defended from then he was
consigned to hell and then all that old
stuff comes back to haunt Alan
Dershowitz supposedly well anyway first
wits makes the case the Harvard Law
professor he makes the case against
impeach me yesterday and he says listen
you guys keep saying quid pro quo I do
not think those words mean what you
think they mean right quid pro quo
happens all the time in foreign policy
now this is a correct defense here's
Alan Dershowitz let's assume a
Democratic president tells Israel that
foreign aid authorized by Congress will
not be sent or an oval office meeting
will not be scheduled unless the
Israelis stop building settlements quid
pro quo
I might just approve of such a quid pro
quo demand on policy grounds but it
would not constitute an abuse of power
quid pro quo alone is not a basis for
abuse of power it's part of the way
foreign policy has been operated by
presidents since the beginning of time
okay this was always the best defense
right this is always the best defense
and in fact Pam Bondi laid out a very
similar defense yesterday because she
was pointing out that quid pro quo is
something that people do all the time
and when Democrats do it it's not even
considered a terrible thing right in
fact it wasn't even Pam Bondi it was
another lawyer Eric Hirshman rather
who's a trump defense guy and he says
listen if you're talking about
impeaching Trump over a quid pro quo on
foreign policy remember that time that
Barack Obama literally sat with Dmitry
Medvedev who is the cutout for Vladimir
Putin and said to him then that I will
do something on missile defense but
you're gonna need to give me flexibility
until after the election that is
literally what Barack Obama said so Erik
Hersman points this out this is trending
on Twitter last night how dare anyone
mentioned the sainted Obama it's amazing
the minute you mentioned Obama in any
context Twitter goes nuts because Obama
as we all know from the media coverage
the only scandal Obama ever had is that
he wore its han suit nothing ever
happened the IRS nothing ever happened
with the HHS never nothing ever happened
fast and furious nothing ever happened
with Russia the Obama administration was
scandal free right that's the line of
the media so the minute that you
mentioned the fact that Barack Obama
acted in fairly corrupt ways on foreign
policy
see and suddenly it's the end of the
world okay but let us remember I'm gonna
read you the actual transcript of what
Barack Obama said to Dmitry Medvedev
that was caught on a hot mic transcript
Obama on all of these issues but
particularly missile defense this this
can be solved but it's important for him
to give me spiced talking about Putin
and Medvedev says yes I understand
understand their message about space
space for you and Obama said this is my
last election after my election I have
more flexibility and Medvedev says I
understand I will transmit this
information to Vladimir yeah that's a
pretty obvious quid pro quo Erik Hersman
points out this is a pretty obvious quid
pro quo President Obama used the powers
of the presidency in a manner that
compromised the national security of the
United States in undermined the
integrity of the United States
democratic process he thus ignored and
injured the interest of the nation close
quote does it sound familiar house
managers it should as the case against
President Obama would have been far
stronger than the allegations against
President Trump President Obama's abuse
the power to benefit his own political
interests was there and is here now for
everyone to hear
it was a direct unquestionable quid pro
quo okay so again he is correct about
all of this he is correct about all of
this and the fact is that this was
always Trump's best defense which is
that you may not like what presidents do
but this is why we have elections there
on impeach presidents who engage in
foreign policy quid pro quos even when
they benefit them politically like the
reason that he was saying he has
flexibility after the election is
because he is saying back off back off
until the election and then after the
election I have more flexibility as to
pursuing missile defense in other words
if you wait until after the election
then maybe I'll go soft on Eastern
European missile defense with regard to
Russia
right so Obama did that back in 2012 I
remember his big thing right was big
ding but that was never at any point
purported to be because of an
impeachment affair right that was that
was perceived to be a good reason not to
reelect the guy which the American
people then didn't take into account
obviously didn't matter hey but the the
notion that the quid pro quo that Trump
was engaged in with Ukraine was
fundamentally not illegitimate or at
least not impeachable
right that was always the best defense
but again the problem for Trump and team
Trump is that they didn't make that
defense because Trump forbade them from
making that defense because Trump is not
his own best defense attorney Trump
strategy whenever he is accused of a
thing is to pretend that the thing never
ever happened and the problem is that
further facts tend to corroborate the
fact that it happened even if it wasn't
as bad Trump doesn't understand that the
basic political rule which is that the
cover-up is usually worse than the crime
is absolutely truth Trump every
activity in which Trump has allegedly
engaged that has caused legal trouble
for him has been an activity where the
cover-up was worse than the actual crime
I take for example stormy Daniels yeah
it turns out that it's not great when
you stub ladies who aren't your wife and
our porn stars while your wife is
pregnant turns out that's a bad thing to
do you know what turns that into a for
criminal investigation when you start
telling your lawyer how to funnel money
to storming Daniels to shut her up
right at that point that's when all of a
sudden this balloons out and becomes a
bigger issue you know what is actually
not that huge deal or at least it's it's
a it may be a big deal but really is not
it's more like you're just mouthing off
when you tell randos that you don't like
the ambassador to ukraine when you told
Randle's like web partners yeah we had a
conversation and I said I don't like
that ambassador and if you have any
information on her let me know
that's not actually anything close to
impeachable if Trump just said that all
right not great not fond of it don't
like the tactic think it's immoral but
is it impeachable no but then when you
say I've never met enough diamonds I
don't know who that pianist is don't
know I'm from Adam and then he brings a
tape forth in which you are talking with
him explicitly about the subject of the
investigation then it becomes an issue
if you just say listen sure it was a
quid pro quo I was looking into 2016
then we're all like okay I mean I like
that I may think you're operating on the
back of bad information in confirmation
bias
it doesn't seem impeachable me the
minute you say however that that never
happened at all now you have a factual
dispute and a factual dispute is always
going to subject you to more scrutiny
and more investigations and that is why
the media are jumping all over the
Boulton thing that's why the Bolton
thing is a problem for Trump is not a
problem for him in terms of impeachment
it is a problem for him in terms of this
thing being dragged out because right
now we're in the middle of the twenty20
election right now the best thing for
Trump is to get this thing behind him
what Trump would like is for this to not
be an issue moving forward we can talk
about the great economy we can talk
about his foreign policy accomplishments
we can talk about all of those things
but if we're talking about john bolton
that's not great for the president
now one of the one of the things that
that this has led to of course is the
media to be able to try and condemn
Trump's supporters as utterly crazy
right because now you have john bolton
going up directly against the president
people who like john bolton five seconds
ago now hate john bolton you're seeing
people who hate john bolton generally on
foreign policy now trying to condemn him
as a democratic stooge this has been
happening I think Tucker Carlson and Lou
Dobbs both did this last night which is
of course very silly jump Alton it's not
either scootch there's only one group of
people who hate Tucker who hate John
Bolton more than Tucker Carlson and Lou
Dobbs and that is Democrats they despise
John Bolton until today right the fact
is that if you're a Trank paint john
bolton is a liar and this is now test of
credibility between Donald Trump and
John Bolton that's not going to end
great for Donald Trump now does that
mean that this thing isn't gonna blow
back on Democrats no we're gonna get to
that in just one second because here's
the problem as we move into 2020 the
person on the Democratic side who's most
likely to be hit over all of us is Joe
Biden
which means that Bernie Sanders is more
likely to become the nominate which
we'll get to in a moment also first
let's talk about how it's kind of
pointless to go to the post office now I
like the post office post office is
great but schlepping all of these
packages to the post office is a pain in
the butt you got to put them all in your
car you gotta unload them all from your
car you only got two hands yeah bring a
dolly you gotta wait in line right
instead of doing all of that stuff why
not just do it quickly and easily from
your own home you can do this and you
can do it more cheaply with stamps.com
with Sam's comm you save five cents off
every first-class stamp up to 40% off
shipping rates it's a lot of savings it
can really add up if you're a small
business particularly stamps.com brings
all the services of the US Postal
Service directly to your computer if
your small office sending invoices and
online sellers shipping out products
even a warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day stamps comm can handle it
all with ease simply use your computer
to print official US postage 24/7 for
any letter any package any class of mail
anywhere you would like to send it
stamps comm not only saves you time it
saves you money as well you get those
discounted postage rates and right now
my listeners get a special offer here's
the special offer you get a four week
trial plus free postage and digital
scale no long term commitment which is a
great deal right you got nothing to lose
just go to stamps comm click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
type in Shapiro that is stamps comm
enter Shapiro again stamps.com
promo code Shapiro go type that in right
now and get your special deal at
stamps.com saves you all sorts of time
I've been using stamps comm for years
and
leave you before they were an advertiser
I was using stamps calm so go check them
out right now and use that code Shapiro
okay now it's not just gonna blow back
on Trump this is this whole impeachment
hearing obviously it's gonna have some
impact on Joe Biden and the reason for
that is because what was at the center
of this whole Trump wanting to know
about Ukraine stuff was his suspicion of
Joe Biden well yesterday Pam Bondi who
is one of trumps lawyers former attorney
general in San Florida she came forward
and she gave a case against hunter Biden
that's pretty damning because the
reality is that no matter whether you
think Joe Biden is pure as the driven
snow or what hunter Biden certainly is
not here is Pam Bondi going after a
hundred Biden verissimo was so corrupt
that George Kant said he intervened to
prevent US aid from co-sponsoring an
event with Purisima you know what
dissident was it was a child's contest
so hunter Biden is paid over eighty
three thousand dollars a month hunter
Biden had no experience and natural gas
no experience in the energy sector no
experience with Ukrainian regulatory
affairs as far as we know he doesn't
speak Ukrainian ABC Good Morning America
The Washington Post The New York Times
Ukrainian law enforcement and the Obama
State Department itself they all thought
there was cause to raise the issue about
the Biden's
and parisa okay all of this is a hundred
percent true
Beth Bauman writing in for townhall.com
talks about this today says although
former Vice President Joe Biden
repeatedly talked about ending
corruption ABC News launched an
investigation called hunter Biden's
foreign deals it talks about Biden's
dealings with Purisima and even in China
less than two weeks after the VP and his
son were seen in China hunters firm had
new business with the
government-controlled Bank of China
Bondi explained in fact every person who
was asked about hundred Biden's
involvement with Purisima agreed there
was a potential appearance of a conflict
of interest
multiple House Democrat witnesses
including those from the Department of
State the NSC and others unanimously
testified there was a potential
appearance of conflicts of interest and
that of course is a hundred percent true
so all of this does have an impact on
Joe Biden's electability and right now
this is the problem for Biden Biden's
entire case for being the nominee is his
electability so Biden is now caught in a
vise he's caught in a vise on the one
hand Democrats believe that Donald Trump
is having real trouble in this election
they look at the national polling and
they see that Donald Trump is trailing
to all of their major candidates and
they say okay well Trump has a
pathological inability to keep his mouth
shut
Trump says wild things on a regular
basis he did not perform well for
Republicans in 2018 and so he did win
the popular vote in 2016 we don't think
that we need to run somebody super
electable to beat Donald Trump in 2020
so on the one hand Democrats are
overestimating the unpopularity of
Donald Trump because they look at Trump
and they say this is a person who makes
a lot of mistakes we could run a ham
sandwich against this guy and win and
then on the other hand they're looking
at your Biden and they're seeing
somebody who is doddering somebody who's
old and somebody who is now implicated
in questions about corruption which
really hurts him when he is attempting
to attack Trump on character grounds if
you're trying to attack Trump as a as a
corrupt actor and in the meantime you're
weathering charges that your son was
cashing in on your last name you got a
problem on your hands
and so Biden's candidacy is now caught
in the middle and he has no rock core of
enthusiasm there's no enthusiasm for his
candidacy and so what you're starting to
see is him fade in places like Iowa and
New Hampshire which means that right now
the odds-on favorite for the Democratic
nomination is a geriatric communist
Bernie Sanders which is unbelievable
good for Trump in the sense that if he
had the sort of handpick a candidate
Trump can run against it would be Bernie
horrible for the country and that half
the country will now resonate to a
communist message and not only will they
resonate to the messages of a crime by
the way when he says Democratic
Socialist he doesn't mean Democratic
Socialist that is just him putting a
friendly face on all this the heads of
Norway and Denmark will talk in copious
detail about the glories of capitalism
Bernie Sanders woman people mad he
thinks the capitalism is in and of
itself a system of greed and evil but
that guy is likely to be the Democratic
nominee at this point we'll get to that
in just one second first let's talk
about that time they had a breakdown in
your car and you had to go to the kind
of generic auto parts store and they
gave you the runaround finally they gave
you a part the part wasn't the right
part wouldn't have been better if you
had access to all of the parts you know
the specific part that fit your specific
car and particularly if you're an auto
enthusiast like I know people who are
really into cars
work on their own cars on regular basis
they like antique cars you need that
special part right it's not like you can
just go and pick up any part at the auto
parts store for some overpriced for some
overpriced price instead what you need
is the power of the Internet and this is
where Rock Auto calm comes in
rockauto.com is a family business
serving Auto Parts customers online for
20 years you can head over to
rockauto.com and shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds of manufacturers
they have everything from engine control
modules and brake parts to tail lamps
motor oil even new carpet whether it's
for your classic or your daily driver
get everything you need in a few easy
clicks delivered directly to your door
the rockauto.com catalog is really easy
to navigate you can quickly see all the
parts available for your vehicle you can
filter by brands specifications and
prices I'm not a car guy but I know with
certainty that I can find the part that
I need when I go to rockauto.com if you
are a car guy that is true to an
exponential degree because you need very
specific parts best of all prices at
rockauto.com are always reliably low and
the same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers they've got great
selection reliably low prices all the
parts your car will ever need Rock Auto
calm head on over to rockauto.com right
now see all the parts available for your
car or truck right shapiro and their how
did you hear about us box so they know
that we sent you so as we see the fact
is that right now joe biden has some
serious trouble he has some serious
trouble and the points that he makes
about Bernie Sanders are correct the
problem is that Joe Biden has always
been a weak candidate and at a certain
point here that means that Barack Obama
is going to be the one who has a choice
at a certain point here Barack Obama is
going let's say the Bernie wins Iowa in
New Hampshire at that point Barack Obama
has a one-time opportunity to step in
and stop all this nonsense at that point
Barack Obama will need to come out and
say listen I don't think Barney can win
I trust Joe I know Joe drills my map
right and then he will have the
opportunity to prop Joe Biden up to the
nomination but if he does not it seems
as though Bernie Sanders is the one with
all the momentum at this point Joni
Ernst senator from Iowa she says listen
you know I'm looking at this trial I'm
wondering if voters are gonna support
Biden given the fact that the hunter
Biden stuff is on the table now Iowa
caucuses folks Iowa caucuses are this
next Monday
evening and I'm really interested to see
how this discussion today informs and
influences the Iowa caucus voters those
Democratic caucus goers will they be
supporting present Vice President Biden
at this point okay now Republicans you
can see they're grinning about this
they're rooting for it Republicans are
saying we'd love to run against Bernie
Sanders let me just remind you folks
whenever people say here's who I would
like to run against beware I'm old
enough remember when a lady named
Hillary Clinton was encouraging Donald
Trump to run in 2016 because she would
love to have run against Donald Trump
she got her wish and now she's wandering
the woods of Chappaqua while Donald
Trump is sitting in the Oval Office
laughing at her and tweeting about her
on a regular basis be careful what you
wish for politics is the monkey's paw
man you can wish for what you want but
it may not end up being exactly what you
want as I say Biden's critiques of
Bernie Sanders are absolutely correct
like Joe Biden came out yesterday he
says listen Sanders doesn't know how
much his plans cost Sanders doesn't know
what the hell he's talking about
but this is the point the people who
love Sanders love that he doesn't know
how much his plan costs the people who
love Sanders love that he's impractical
and insane they love the fact that none
of what he's saying makes sense because
he's promising them a better world this
is always the promise of Marxism Marxism
has never worked anywhere the best that
Marxist programs can do is live off the
back of capitalism like leeches and
redistribute the profits and the
products that are created by the free
market that is the best thing that any
sort of socialistic program can do they
can't create anything new they cannot
generate new prosperity there has never
been a socialist program anywhere in the
world that has done any of these things
okay but the problem is that if you are
Bernie Sanders and you're pledging
people a greater world your vagueness is
your appeal see Bernie Sanders didn't
make the same mistake the Elizabeth
Warren made there's a reason Elizabeth
Warren has been taking a dump in the
polls the reason that she's been
following in the polls is because she
made the crucial error she tried to put
meat on the bones of Bernie Sanders ISM
but there's a problem
he can't put meat on those bones they
don't sustain the weight so when
Elizabeth Warren came out and she was
like let me explain to you how I'm gonna
pay for all of this I'm going to I'm
going to find money in the anus of a of
a unicorn and I'm going to use that to
pay for this 19 trillion dollar health
care program that actually costs 33
trillion dollars but I'm gonna call it
19 trillion dollars by double counting
all this money when people said
when she did that and everybody laughed
at her it was like oh because suddenly
the fantasy had been made reality and it
turns out that everybody had been
fantasizing about the Victoria's Secret
model and what they actually got in the
mail was the not online version of the
match.com profile right it turns out
that communism is a match.com profile
communism looks real nice in the
match.com profile photo and then they
show up at the coffee bean and it turns
out they're a hideous old hag right that
that is it that is communism
well the problem is that elizabeth
warren made that clear Bernie Sanders is
still pushing the match.com profile pic
of communism the minute that he gets
down to real reality with regard to his
plans then it then begins to fall apart
and Democrats keep trying to drag him
down and say okay well here's the
reality of your plan people who love
Bernie don't want to hear the reality of
the plan they are forcibly they are
forcibly suspending their disbelief
Bernie Sanders is a movie to them he is
not an actual program he's a dream and
when you pitch a dream it's very hard to
get people to wake up so here's Joe
Biden trying to get people to wake up
good luck to him it's not one of those
things where as one of the leaders of
the effort for Medicare for all said I
don't know how much it's going to cost I
don't know what it's going to be we're
just going to have to do it well I said
not a likely way to pass something
through the Senate saying I don't know
how much it's going to cost and the
person is offering it so we got to get
real about what we can do to protect
people's health here okay but you can
see the difference in the crowds okay so
here's Biden speaking yesterday if you
saw the tape yesterday a Bernie Sanders
speaking it's all young people it's all
young people and in Iowa that matters in
Iowa that makes a big difference now
Bernie Sanders is counting on all those
young people to show up and vote for him
in the 2020 election I'm not sure that
that's a good bet for him but it is
obvious that everybody above the age of
65 supports Joe Biden and nobody under
the age of so under the age of 40
supports Joe Biden Biden by the way also
is saying that he can take a punch
that is quite unclear at this point
given the fact that he has not risen in
the polls he's basically stagnated in
the polls and he's run a very poorly
organized campaign here is here is Joe
Biden who basically was trying to limp
his way to to contention here I mean it
felt a lot less it feels a lot like Jeb
Bush in the latter days here is Joe
Biden as much as he's trying to destroy
me and my family I hope I've
demonstrated I
take a punch and if I might not me he's
gonna understand what punches mean ok
well that does not sound good when you
are slurring your words it does not
sound like a robust defense of yourself
when you are slurring your words so
right now it appears that that Bernie
Sanders has the upper hand in this race
now is he electable this is this is the
question that Democrats are now asking
themselves
has he been vetted is he electable if
you go on Twitter the the conventional
wisdom on Twitter is he's super
electable and anybody who says he's not
electable is crazy now that's crazy okay
Bernie Sanders has been elected in
Vermont which has seven people and he's
been elected one thousand times in a
state he's basically been living on the
public dime since the man was thirty
years old and he was on unemployment in
his thirties like he was he was I'm like
it's ridiculous so the notion that that
makes him broadly electable across the
country silly on the one hand I don't
think he's super electable on the other
hand he's got a shot and putting a
communist in a position where he might
have a shot at the presidency seems like
problem will get through the
electability arguments with regard to
Bernie Sanders in just one second first
if you know anything about this show you
know this is an extremely a pro-life
show last year I spoke at the March for
Life did my podcast live and gave a
speech to hundreds of thousands of
people who are marching for the cause
this caused us an enormous amount of
grief from our political adversaries who
literally sit there trying to take words
out of context on this show just to
attack our advertisers last year we lost
a lot of revenue because of that that
will be the first time when we say
pro-life things when we say true things
there are people on the left you spend
their days attempting to take down this
show and we're not the only targets our
friends over a live action have been
targeted by the folks at social media
they've been banned from advertising on
Twitter they've been banned from posting
altogether on Pinterest live action is a
fantastic pro-life group run by my
friend Lila Rose I give money to live
action personally I think they're
fantastic well right now we have a
special deal if you go to daily we're
calm from now until January 31st you can
speak up not only on behalf of
conservative positions you can also help
out the pro-life cause when you use
promo code live-action so if you go to
daily we're calm and you get a
membership with promo code at live
action part of that don't part of that
membership will be donated to live
actions so you're giving money to us but
you're also giving money to an
explicitly pro-life group that does
great educational work about abortion
join daily wire.com it make your
pro-life at voice heard we had the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
so one of the reasons that Democrats are
downplaying the the electability
problems of Bernie Sanders is because
they are in love with the sound of their
own voices they have come to the
conclusion that the people who support
Donald Trump are seven there are seven
of them and that they're all crazy and
this is the way that really this is the
way that the media talk about supporters
of Donald Trump not just Trump himself
by ripping on trumpet look Trump's the
president you can rip on him as much as
you want but Hillary Clinton made a bad
mistake in the 2016 election when she
suggested that everybody who supported
Donald Trump was a deplorable it was a
huge mistake same sort of mistake that
Barack Obama made in 2008 the media
covered for him but it was a mistake
when he suggested that everyone who's
gonna vote for his opponent was a bitter
clinger well now members of the media
are full-on endorsing this point of view
I mean laughing at people who support
Trump they're all a bunch of toothless
Hicks from the south now many of these
people I really doubt have spent a lot
of time in the modern South but they
have this image that the south is
basically a bunch of cartoon characters
from 1840 anyway Rick Wilson who used to
be a true never Trump Republican right a
guy who not only opposed Trump in 2016
but has determined that Trump is now the
font of all evil and must be stopped at
any cost including voting for Democrats
which is just ridiculous in my view he
was on CNN yucking it up with Don Lemon
and in the course of this clip you're
gonna hear what Democrats actually think
of Republicans because they think this
they think that they can actually run a
geriatric socialist for the presidency
of the United States
and win because after all the Donald
Trump supporters are a bunch of
toothless morons he knows that this is
you know an administration defined by
ignorance of the world and so that's
partly him playing to their base and
playing to their audience you know the
the the credulous Boomer Rube demo that
backs Donald Trump that wants to think
that that that dog Trump's a smart one
in there oh y'all know y'all elitist
rube you would lead us with your
geography and your maps and your
spelling even though my bath you're
reading yeah you're reading you know
your geography no in other countries
sipping your latte all those lines on
the map look at that reporting that's
CNN the most trusted name in news the
most trusted name in news laughs and
with it with
southern accent because the only
ignorant people in America is you know
our people with southern accents that's
not biased in any way also the notion
that everybody who's voting for Donald
Trump is a rube and a hick who doesn't
know their geography I mean it's this
sort of it's this sort of take on
politics that could come back to bite em
across directly in the ass because if
they have decided that they're writing
off half the country they did this in
2016 a half the country are racist
sexist bigoted homophobes they're doing
the same thing now but they've upped the
ante cuz this is how this is how much
they hate Trump they hate Trump so much
that Trump is now a prism for how they
view every other human being it's not
that there are a lot of people who vote
for Trump to stop Bernie Sanders or
voted for Trump to stop Hillary Clinton
or that don't like a lot of what Trump
says or does but like a lot of his
policies no it's that they're a bunch of
hick rubes who don't understand
geography and math we don't know how to
add right which is weird because on
average I believe in the last election
cycle on average Republican voters
averaged a higher income level than
Democratic voters I believe in the last
election cycle if you do it on a
county-by-county level then the
wealthiest counties voted for Hillary
Clinton but if you average the incomes I
believe that the the Democrats were
actually lower income on average than
the Republicans were in the last
election cycle so this idea their bench
a hick rubes voting for Donald Trump
that sort of attitude is what's leading
them to believe okay we can literally
run this old badger communist this old
wobbly from 1918 this guy who had a
picture of Eugene Debs an actual
honest-to-god socialist in his Senate
office four years right we can run that
guy and we can win because we could run
anything and win and that this is again
this is the view not just of the Don
lemons of the world who's just a clown I
mean Don lemons a clown and Rick Wilson
now makes a living just making these
sorts of jokes on MSNBC and and CNN
right he hasn't offered anything that
approaches a substance of criticism for
a while he's basically just sort of
doing insult comedy for the for the
laughs of the people in the media that
sort of stuff that's a campaign ad for
Trump right I mean they just cut a
campaign ad for Trump on CNN the most
trusted name in news and I do love it
when Don Lemon and Chris Cuomo sit there
in Tutt Donald Trump about how mean he
is to people in the media how could he
be so mean to people how could he tweet
mean things I mean you can't stop
yourself hysterically laughing and
hackneyed jokes about how people in the
south don't know how to do math I think
I'm gonna take your hide
with a grain of salt next time but again
it's not just the folks on CNN it's
people like MSNBC's Nicole Wallace we
suggested yesterday that everybody who's
defending Donald Trump in this trial is
a flat earther I've known Chris Wallace
my entire career in politics this isn't
a flappable man and and just the I mean
I called it the Flat Earth Society the
Republicans are clinging to this
argument that the earth is flat Chris
Wallace obviously they're trying to
cover the same wave event we're cover
you can say no we have a first hit
witness who saw the earth it's round and
he's just trying to tell these senators
before they render a judgment that the
facts reveal the earth is indeed round
lots of flat earthers everything is
about a flat earth and everybody who
opposes me is an idiot and that's why we
can run this person who lives in a world
of communist fantasy where the United
States is the biggest problem on planet
Earth and we can run him and he'll win
maybe it'll work maybe it'll work I'm
not suggesting that Bernie Sanders can't
win obviously he can win but is that the
Democrats strongest line of appeal I
have serious doubts about all this
meanwhile the Democrats are
strategically torn in Iowa according to
the New York Times as they streamed out
of the banquet ballroom following a
Scott County fundraiser Saturday night
one after the other Iowa Democrats
admitted they still had not decided whom
to support just over a week before the
state's presidential caucuses but by not
mentioning his name as they rattled off
their shortlist they made clear whom
they would not support senator Bernie
Sanders the Democratic Socialist from
Vermont who has taken the lead in recent
polls by the way I love that the media
have now resonated so just calling him a
Democratic Socialist because he insists
on it I would like to see Bernie Sanders
forcibly disavow communism like explain
what are the ideological problems of
communism has anybody asked him to
distinguish democratic socialism from
socialism like what's the actual
difference what what do you favor about
about democratic socialism that you do
not favor about socialism itself if all
you mean is socialism where people get
to vote on the rules of the tyrannical
government then that's just called
socialism because they do have fake
elections in one party states so what
exactly do you mean because presumably
when he says democratic socialism he
does not mean that the people actually
get to decide on their own economic
fortunes if he actually meant that then
he would not be a socialist right see
here's the thing
I'm a democratic capitalist but what I
mean by that is I'm a capitalist okay
because the reality is I believe there
are certain fundamental rights that are
protected by the United States
Constitution and that democracies cannot
overrule those rights there are certain
rights that are sacrosanct
stitute list there very few people on
planet earth where our pure Democrats
meaning that they think on majority
should decide everything because if you
are a pure Democrat you that's an
unsustainable moral position there is no
one on planet earth even the most
quote-unquote populous minded people who
believe that pure majorities should
simply decide everything in the world
because of a pure majority decide to
kill the minority presumably you would
not be in favor of democracy at that
point there are certain sacrosanct
principles you care about so adding the
word democratic to socialist does not
change the math you have to explain what
you mean by socialist so what what in
Marxism does Bernie Sanders is like why
has nobody ever asked him explain to me
in pure detail why we should not
nationalize this particular industry why
should we not nationalize an industry
explain to me why the free market is
good right you say that you're a
democratic socialist like Norway well
instead of just using the term
democratic socialist why are you
explaining to me
what about Norway is good in terms of
the free market not the side you always
talk about like the nationalized health
care we got the one nationalized health
care the question is why you don't want
to nationalize the oil and gas industry
in the United States why you don't want
to nationalize every other aspect of
industry and why you don't want to
nationalize the stock market like
explain to me why that is why is Bernie
never been asked that question why is it
that if he just says Democratic in front
of socialist we all assume we know what
he's talking about it's this double game
that he plays routinely with regard to
the language but really he plays it all
the time because his higher principle is
not democracy because no one's highest
principle is pure majoritarian democracy
and if you say that it is that's
actually a moral right there are certain
principles you hold above democracy
I hold individual rights above democracy
I do I don't think that if you I don't
think you get to vote to kill your
neighbor I don't think you get to vote
to steal your neighbor's property Bernie
Sanders presumably believes they that no
matter how many people vote in favor of
private healthcare that is still immoral
and then that should be that should
presumably be overridden by the powers
of government there are no rights that
are protected from government so what
exactly is Bernie Sanders mean by
democratic socialists that is different
in any way from socialist in any case
the New York Times is reporting that
there are a lot of people who are
against Bernie but are divided on how
exactly to approach the situation with
regard to Bernie and the problem is that
the more that are divided the more
Bernie Sanders core base makes sense in
2016 this is exactly what happened to
Trump there are a lot of people who are
not gonna vote for Trump in Iowa or New
Hampshire in fact Trump lost Iowa but
Trump's base
strong-enough his core was strong enough
that he was able to weather a very
fractured field Michelle Goldberg who's
been rooting for Bernie all along over
at the New York Times
she says it's no longer far-fetched to
think Sanders could be the Democratic
nominee and then she talks about how
he's got all the buzz and now let's just
understand this is Bernie Sanders his
actual candidacy okay there's a Michelle
Goldberg a fan of Bernie Sanders
describing what happened at his rally
the other night there's a band that
played when the band was done three
indigenous women took the stage to pay
respects to the Native Americans forced
off the land that became Iowa the
filmmaker Michael Moore came on and
described Donald Trump as the end points
of a country founded on genocide and
built on the backs of slaves the next
day at a campaign stop in Perry Moore
called women's under-representation in
Congress a form of gender apartheid aoc
spoke and said I'm here because senator
Sanders is actually committed to
breaking up ice is this what Americans
are ready for seriously I don't care how
much Americans hate Trump you think that
that's not going to be a campaign for
Trump seriously you think the American
people are ready to declare that America
should not exist because of the
exploitation of land seized from Native
Americans because America was a country
built on genocide and slavery because
Congress is engaging in gender apartheid
and because it's time to break up
immigration enforcement I mean it's
unbelievable
that's an unbelievable standard that you
think you're going to be able to
overcome here so good luck with that
good luck with that that doesn't mean
he's not electable he is electable
because anybody's electable once there's
a final - anybody can win a Jeremy
Corbyn could have been Prime Minister of
Britain and until the very last minute
when Boris Johnson blew him out there
were people who thought he was gonna win
businesses were preparing to leave so
it's very dangerous game to play to make
Bernie Sanders the nominee from a
Republican point of view from a
democratic point of view however is he
more vulnerable than any other
Democratic candidate who's up there no
question no question okay meanwhile this
week marks the 75th anniversary of the
liberation of Auschwitz by Allied forces
and people who experienced the Holocaust
are worried about the increase in
anti-semitism across the world as well
they should be New York Times reports
the ceremony at Auschwitz culminated a
week of events around the world
including a commemoration in Jerusalem
attended by dozens of world leaders who
urged collective vigilance against a
resurgence of anti-semitism worldwide
and that is exactly right but the
problem is that that anti-semitism
has been mainstreamed into the left the
left refuses to acknowledge its own
anti-semitism it's very easy to
acknowledge and point out the
anti-semitism of white supremacist
groups who go around shooting up
synagogues I've been a mile away from a
shooting of a white supremacy premises I
mean that shooting that happened in near
San Diego I was very close to that to
that location at the time III
Scholz in my in my neighborhood have
been fire bombed before so like the
anti-semitism of white supremacist has
been well known in America by Jews for a
very long time around the world the
problem is the mainstreaming of Muslim
anti-semitism radical Islamic
anti-semitism by the left is ongoing and
wild and ignored by the left for for
like truly ignored they don't care about
anti-semitism unless it serves their
purposes which is why Rashida to leave
in Ilhan Omar on a committee holding a
hearing of this week in the house about
Holocaust Memorial Day Rasheeda Talib
who literally pushed a blood libel over
the weekend suggesting that Jews
kidnapped a Palestinian child and then
drowned him in a well that woman will be
over I mean that is classical
anti-semitism will be overseeing sitting
on a committee that discusses Holocaust
Memorial Day illa Hanna Omar who has
never missed an opportunity to be a
raging anti-jew anti-semite tweeted out
yesterday on international Holocaust
Remembrance Day we mourn the lives of
six million Jews who were systematically
murdered today and every day we must
redouble our efforts to confront
anti-semitism and all forms of religious
discrimination and say hashtag never
again which is insane because illa Han
Omar is a supporter of terror groups a
year ago she tried to pass a boycott
while comparing Israel to Nazi Germany
one year ago and she's mainstream that
right she is she's gonna be at that
hearing presumably proclaiming that
Donald Trump is the real anti-semite
while she continues to support the cause
of the palestine liberation organization
run by actual holocaust denier mahmoud
abbas i it's so funny now Trump is gonna
put out his peace plan today he's
putting out his peace plan today and his
peace plan basically just acknowledges
the realities on the ground the
realities on the ground are that there
are Jewish settlements those Jewish
settlements are not going to be uprooted
in favor of a terror state it's not a
thing that's going to happen Jerusalem
is not going to be divided and no there
is no quote-unquote Palestinian right of
return there has never been in human
history a quote unquote right of return
of a population that that has left by a
majority group
that does not wish to retake those
people in okay the fact is that even
Zionism was approved by the British man
tape by the British Mandate people were
moving in at the behest and with the
willingness of the group that was there
and they were not there to quote-unquote
destroy the ruling mandate okay the fact
is the Palestinians have openly stated
that they are there in order to destroy
the State of Israel they've never
accepted the existence of the State of
Israel and the idea that you're going to
rectify all imbalances by destroying the
State of Israel that's not anti-semitic
is bizarre in the extreme the idea that
Israel has a peace partner is bizarre in
the extreme Mahmoud Abbas right Malcolm
and Abbas is an open Holocaust denier he
literally wrote his his thesis he wrote
a college thesis about is a doctoral
thesis in 1982 questioning the extent of
the Nazi genocide so those are the
people that Israel is facing down and we
are told that if Israel does not make
concessions to those people then
obviously Israel is the problem but
don't worry we all hate anti-semitism
and we're all fighting anti-semitism
it's just an sighs it's it is
anti-semitism being accepted across the
board watch watch the blowback to the
Trump peace plan today in which the soft
bigotry of anti-semitism is allowed to
flourish in which Palestinians suggest
that Jews are only colonial oppressors
from the West and shouldn't be on the
land in the first place and they decide
that they're going to protest the idea
that there should be a Jewish state in
the first place the don't worry it's not
anti-semitism it's just anti-zionism and
not only that the Palestinians have a
right to swamp the Jewish state with
populations that weren't even born in
those areas in the first place not just
a right of return to quote-unquote the
new state of Palestine but a right to
return to their original homes a right
that has never existed in human history
so far as I am aware considering that
there are borders that exist but
nonetheless the left will continue to
pretend that anti-semitism is a figment
of the right-wing imagination when it
comes to the left and only exists on the
right and Muslim anti-semitism which is
the greatest threat to the future of
Jews living on planet earth that that is
not really a problem in the first place
alrighty time for a quick thing I like
and then a thing that I hate so if you
want to know more about the
quote/unquote right of return and why
the Palestinian right of return has
always been a fig leaf if you want to
know you know the real facts about why
it is that this is such a ridiculous
argument that hundreds of thousands of
Palestinians who either voluntarily left
or left in the midst
of a war in 1948 that they and their
descendants should be allowed to return
to their original homes when Jews were
forcibly expelled like hundreds of
thousands of them and absorbed by the
nascent State of Israel
if you want to understand why the right
of return was always a bad faith attempt
to destroy the State of Israel all you
have to do is read a book by Adi
Schwartz and I not Wilf called the wall
of the war of return how Western
indulgence of the Palestinian dream has
obstructed the path to peace that is
coming out I believe very shortly I
think is coming out in April so you can
pre-order it now the book is excellent
and you should know Adi Schwartz and I
not wolf are not right-wing activists
both of them works for the Labour Party
in Israel which is the far left party in
Israel they were both part of the
negotiations of Oslo and they've
recognized that everybody has sort of
ignored this in every peace deal when
when Trump presents his peace plan
you know everybody on the left's gonna
go what about the right to return what
about the right to return why aren't the
Palestinians allowed to go back to their
original homes well the Jews were not
allowed to go back to their original
homes there is again never been a record
like when we talk about refugees usually
you talk about how refugees cannot be
barred they cannot be barred from going
somewhere else right but usually when
you talk about refugees there's very
little talk about resettling them in the
place where they originally came from
against the against the wishes of the
ruling government right that is that is
not something that has historically been
precedented the only exception is this
right so the this is the one area where
the West has kept this ridiculousness
alive and the reason for that is because
this has been pushed by the Palestinian
leadership and the Palestinian
leadership is pushed for it because they
understand that in swapping the State of
Israel with now what would be four
million registered Palestinians
according to the UN rwi something like
that that they would be destroying the
State of Israel which of course is the
ultimate goal here now what's amazing
about the Trump peace plan that is gonna
be presented today is not only does it
recognize realities on the ground but
also there's a good shot that a lot of
the Arab states are basically going to
say of course this should be the basis
of further negotiation because the truth
is that as as states like Saudi Arabia
and Egypt and Jordan recognize that the
Palestinians just wants to destroy the
State of Israel they've always
understood that but they understand that
the greater threat now is not the State
of Israel never was the State of Israel
it's actually Iran they've started to
worry less about the the fake claims of
the Palestinians that they're going to
destroy the State of Israel and wipe all
the Jews into the sea
instead they have decided that pursuing
peace is actually a possibility if
pieces to be pursued than the right of
return which was always a talking point
and always nonsense is going to have to
be dropped because it is indeed nonsense
it will have to be dropped it was never
a reality to begin with it was always a
fig leaf for attempting to destroy the
State of Israel in the first place so
check it out the war of return Audie
Schwartz and I not wolf and it explains
in much fuller detail why the quote
unquote right of return is historically
inaccurate historically foolhardy is an
obstacle to any sort of peace deal in
the first place by the way Israel is
desperate to make a peace deal they
would love nothing better than to have a
peace partner that they could just hand
this off to and be like okay we don't
want anything to do with this
enjoy like that Israel every Israeli
every Israeli Prime Minister for the
last 30 years has wanted to do this the
problem is that nobody who's running the
show over there in the West Bank or the
Gaza Strip is trustworthy because
they're all Holocaust denying terrorists
would like to destroy every Jew living
in the region ranging from Tel Aviv to -
not just worrying about you know Chevron
or any of the other quote-unquote
settlements okay time for a quick thing
that I hate okay so Stephen King made a
big boo-boo the other day a big terrible
boo-boo so he tweeted out I would never
consider diversity in matters of art
only quality it seems to me that to do
otherwise would be wrong
oh no Stephen King you're not allowed to
say that so Stephen King who I'll admit
I enjoy Stephen King's books at least
the premises of his books he always
writes books that have really
interesting sort of beginnings and then
mediocre middles and then the end
everything just explodes like that's
that's the end of every one of his book
every one of his books is there's a
giant explosion really every single one
like from the stand to to the shining to
like all of them and with just like
there's a big explosion you know okay I
guess that's a way to end a book okay I
suppose
in any case Stephen King who is a wild
leftist right he hates Trump he hates
conservatives really hates them and if
you read any of his books they are
wildly biased against the right every
one of his books is about some small
town in Maine or repressive
right-wingers are trying to shut down
the local lesbians and like it's every
single one of his books is like this
they're all about repressive
right-wingers who study the Bible too
much I don't know what happened in his
childhood but clearly he has a real
problem with people who have ever read
the Bible and he believes the same
things that Rick Wilson believes about
ignorant people and their political
beliefs
he tweets out this highly controversial
thing right I would never consider
diversity in matters of art only quality
it seems to me that to do otherwise
would be wrong
really that to do otherwise would be so
he says that correct correct when we
look at art we should be looking at the
quality of art but the blowback was
fierce and now he has been forced to do
a mayic up a struggle session in the
pages of the Washington Post
so now Stephen King the whitest person
in the world he he has a piece called
the Oscars are still rigged in favor of
white he had to have a full-on struggle
session so after acknowledging that
maybe we should you know judge art based
on its own merits now he's like but if
it's not made by black people that's
because of racism that's because of
racism so Stephen King rights
discussions of Arts and Culture like
discussions of politics have become
increasingly acrimonious and polarized
in recent years lines of belief are
drawn with indelible ink and if you step
over them wittingly or unwittingly you
find yourself in the social media
version of the stocks and subject to a
barrage of electronic turnips and
cabbages I stepped over one of those
lines recently by saying on Twitter
something that I thought mistakenly was
non-controversial and then he cites his
tweet the subject was the Academy Awards
I also said in essence that those
judging creative excellence should be
blind to questions of race gender or
sexual orientation I did not say that
was the case today because nothing could
be further from the truth so here he is
buying it back so he's saying yeah I
think we should probably just you know
consider art along its own merits but
then he's like but the people who
actually vote for the Oscars are vicious
racists guess what I was actually saying
actually I wasn't actually saying that
we should that people who are voting at
the Oscars are voting on quality I'm
saying that I'm the only not racist
person so Stephen King and everybody
else who votes for the Oscars is Supes
dupes racist they're all SuperDuper
racists he says nor did I say that films
novels plays in music focusing on
diversity and or inequality cannot be
works of creative genius they can be and
often are and then he cites when they
see us heading to Bernie's 2019 Netflix
miniseries so going right to the woke is
series he can think of he says has there
been progress in the film community yes
some I'm old enough to remember when
there were only a handful of African
American directors and about the only
female director in Hollywood was Ida
Lupino who made a hard-edged noir B
picks in the 1950s and later worked in
TV her directing work was never
nominated for an Oscar an Emmy for
answers as to why some talented artists
are nominated in some such as Greta
Gerwig
the astoundingly good new version of
Little Women or not you might need to
look no further than the demographic
makeup of those who voted for the
Academy Awards Greta Gerwig was
nominated for Best Director two years
ago for Lady Bird two years ago so
you're telling me that it was all the
sexist in the Academy who nominated her
two years ago but didn't nominate her
today same exact people but there were
sexist today but not two years ago
according to Stephen King it's because
there aren't enough women voting in the
Academy or alternatively this is just
another malice struggle session from
folks on the left or forced to perform
ritual breast-beating get out the sack
cloth and the ashes and weep over their
own unwove nests Stephen King trying to
earn his way back into old circles he
says only eight years ago 94% of 5700
voters were white according to the Los
Angeles Times 77% male 54% more than 60
years old this would women make up 32
percent of voters and minority members
equals 16 percent of the total not good
enough not even within shouting distance
of good enough it's weird because if you
read Stephen King's books they're
disproportionately about white
characters in Maine his Maine is
disproportionately white very odd must
be that he's a racist so this is why he
has to write this because he's a way
that he's a racist then he talks about
how we need to change the constituency
of the of the Academy of the Academy of
Motion Pictures Arts and scientists I
love this he says give them credit for
trying to catch up but not too much
credit of the nine films nominated for
Best Picture this year the majority the
Irishman for versus Ferrari 1917 Joker
and Once Upon a Time in Hollywood are
what my sons call man fiction there are
fights guns and many white faces okay
just like to notice Stephen King's books
fights guns many white faces she's gonna
point that out also going to point out
no one really cares about the white
faces so much but fights and guns have
been historically pretty popular in
movies like going back because it's fun
to watch and also if he can name which
one of those pictures he thinks is
really bad like yeah like I think two of
those movies are not very good I think
the Irishman is terrible movie by the
way and I think the Joker was wildly
over at it but 1917 is a masterpiece
Ford vs. Ferrari it's a fantastic piece
of American film and once upon a time in
Hollywood his Tarantino's best flick
like which one of those things should be
thrown out for little women he's gonna
have to explain and then he talks about
there are movies that are not in serious
contingent they're not in serious
competition for the Oscars like Harriet
okay I saw Harriet it's fine it's fine
is it on the par of any of the other
movies that are nominated no it's like a
normal biopic and I was really excited
about it
I mean I've written my own script about
the John Brown about the John Brown raid
on Harpers Ferry yes I'm very into that
historical period Harriet summons a
character and a script like it would be
great if it were produced but the fact
is that the movie Harriet Tubman it's
like okay it's fine it's not like
unbelievable it's not like Oscar worthy
he says how many people saw the last
black man in San Francisco well not many
but that's because it wasn't in in like
huge wide release with huge publicity
it's it and then he explains that he
doesn't care that in the end even though
a lot of his characters are white he
doesn't really care about race because
he didn't mind when endres elbow was
cast as roland deschain the gunslinger
at the center of the Dark Tower books
and that response reflects my overall
attitude that as with justice judgments
of creative excellence should be blind
but that would be the case in a perfect
world one where the game isn't rigged in
favor of white folk so there it is in
the end he's actually rejecting his own
premise judgments of art should not be
colorblind because we don't live in a
colorblind world and therefore we
certainly should judge the art on the
basis of who the artist is so he has now
performed the ritual breastfeeding and
Stephen King can be welcomed back into
the halls of woken us welcome back
Stephen King and congratulations on your
new conversion really excellent stuff
from the brave Stephen King all right
we'll be back here later today with two
additional hours of content so stick
around for that otherwise we'll see you
here tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling assistant director Pavel I
douse key technical producer Austin
Stevens playback and media operated by
Nick's even associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam sy events audio
is mixed by micro Romina hair and makeup
is by Anika Geneva the ben shapiro show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire 2025 if you want to cut
through the madness of our politics and
culture and know what's really going on
head on over to the michael knowles show
where we can all bask in the simple joys
of being right see you there
[Music]
you